i have a quote here aaron and it reads i
selfishly like a lot of first-time
directors because they over
prepare they are super eager and they
have very little ego
and that quote is from none other than
mark duplass of the duploss brothers i
definitely agree with that um
yeah i think uh i i do think that when
you're a new director you feel like you
have something to prove
and i think it was david f sandberg who
said that you want
to prepare 200 just to get 100
results and i think especially
first-time directors
because they have something to prove or
uh they're nervous they tend to over
prepare a little bit
and when it comes to filmmaking that's
definitely not a bad thing
i i've noticed that my movies get
significantly better if i actually plan
every single shot every single moment
it sounds grueling and tedious and
difficult and it
absolutely is but
it also it also sounds obvious of course
you prepare you do a better job but
it makes a world of a difference i
remember
earlier on in my in my you know career i
remember you
you actually asked if uh what was one of
the biggest mistakes i learned with my
first feature
and i would say not
preparing every single shot
i think especially on a much smaller
budget film
if you actually over prepare you know
exactly what you're gonna shoot and
you're gonna know
every single moment that it is that
you're shooting
uh then the the finished product is
gonna be so much better
did you storyboard do anything like that
i did not storyboard 15 north
it was it was very much again from this
approach of
i just want to get two cameras rolling
at the same time
sort of shoot it in this very mumble
corey documentary style
um didn't want to really do that much
planning
i did have a loose shot list
just to sort of make sure i covered you
know basically got all the coverage that
i needed
but since that movie i've definitely
spent a lot more time
focusing on what's actually in the frame
um on that movie it was just sort of
like let's point a camera at this actor
get their lines and let's just do a
couple takes of that and move on
i don't really do that anymore how does
a writer or filmmaker earn their
audience
that's that's also a good question i i
think a writer filmmaker probably
earns their audience by
being honest with themselves i think
it's like making a friend you know if
you are
if you're a good person and you have
good intentions and you
care about what it is that you're saying
i think people are going to
listen and they're going to be
interested if you
if you seem like you're you know making
a movie or telling a story for all the
wrong reasons
i think that's going to sh it's going to
shine through in your work
so i think you know you you definitely
earn an audience's trust
in that way and then of course you know
the the technical aspect of it
if it looks terrible uh
it's gonna be distracting and nobody
nobody's going to really
even take the time to watch it even if
the content itself
is riveting and good uh you know you
kind of
you sort of need this baseline
production value to
say okay i know what i'm doing
now hear what i have to say and what if
you build an
audience and they become so invested in
your stories and your characters
that they revolt because they
wanted those characters and stories to
become something else but you as the
creator
it's your imagination but how much does
the audience
say involved in some of that how much
say do they have
if i could start a revolution i'd i i'd
be
happy i could i could die early um
i i guess the best example i i mean i've
never really made anything overly
controversial
that would cause anyone to revolt about
anything however there is one
horror short that we just released a few
weeks ago called diet
and we wanted to play with the tropes
of sort of what makes a traditional
horror film
where you just have this you know
usually it's a girl just home alone
and something scary happens she hears a
noise or something is at the window and
she goes up to it
and it's nothing and then she goes into
bed and then turns around there's a
scary monster and
that's it that's the end and it's it's
like the most cliche kind of like little
horror short you could imagine and so i
was thinking of a way to play around
with that
and have all of those same tropes
but then at the very end you just have
that main character die of natural
causes in which case
he just dies of uh choking on a carrot
and then a monster in the closet reveals
herself
and sighs with disappointment because
she couldn't
fulfill her duty as a scary monster who
terrorizes her victims
uh so we released that and i you know i
thought it was like kind of a funny
comedy horror idea
a lot of people were confused by it a
lot of people got it
a lot of people were like what the hell
did i just watch that that doesn't make
any sense
um so that was actually very interesting
and it was particularly interesting to
watch reaction videos of that film
erin are you saying that every horror
short that you do
people do reaction videos too just about
every horror short act
actually i think every horror short that
we've made there are reaction videos
online and and i i do love watching them
some we even have shared a couple to our
social house films
facebook page do they usually let you
know
or do you find them in search there's
only been one person that's ever let us
know
um everyone else just they just do it on
their own
but i mean that's that's fair i they
they don't need to let us know
if they want to watch it and react to it
then so be it you know that's why it's
there
how does that feel that people are that
affected by your work that they're
taking time to make a reaction video
i think it's super cool it's the it's
the
it's just such a cool feeling and
experience to watch someone else
watch what you just made and
literally look them in the eye every
moment of
you know the film that you that you just
put out there
and sometimes you see genuine terror on
their face and it's it's just such a
rewarding thing to see that kind of
visceral response
from a complete stranger
have you ever reached out to a creator
and given feedback
good or bad i tried to get an internship
at apatow productions when i first
moved out here um actually i made a
short horror film
come to think of it it was a short hard
documentary
it was like a mockumentary about the
making of a zombie movie about love
and one of the guys that i made it with
was family friends with larry david and
gave him a copy
and i think i was like i don't know i
was maybe 17 or 18 at this time
and larry david watched it and
told my friend hey tell you know jesse
and aaron
the other filmmakers that they did a
great job and that was a
super cool so i remember kind of pushing
my friend like hey you should you
know larry david you should give this to
him not necessarily his genre but i'd be
curious to you know i'm a huge fan of
larry david so
i'd love to see you know what he thinks
you